femenina
una vieja historia con nuevos personajes
el joven ortega abandonó la facultad de
derecho a sus 17 años para unirse a la
guerrilla sandinista el objetivo
derrocar al dictador anastasio somoza en
1967 cayó en prisión donde estuvo siete
años por robar un banco bajo la causa
comunista salió en libertad tras un
intercambio de rehenes y vivió en el
exilio en cuba y costa rica durante los
años setenta americanos cuando el
movimiento armado derrocó a somoza en
julio de 1979 ortega regresó como un
guerrillero laureado aunque no participó
de ningún combate su compañero no
nombraron el rostro visible de la
revolución sandinista por su calmo
temperamento y será el de más bajo
perfil de los guerrilleros e
intelectuales que gobernaban nicaragua
su primer período como presidente entre
1984 y 1990 estuvo marcado por su
política anti americana el bloqueo
económico y la guerra interna tras el
surgimiento de la contra una guerrilla
entrenada por eeuu para derrocarlo
luego de perder las elecciones en 1990
contra violeta chamorro ortega prometió
gobernar desde las sombras continuó como
el único candidato del sandinismo
durante las siguientes tres elecciones
pero las perdió su popularidad no era
suficiente frente al temor de la guerra
o el servicio militar obligatorio tras
16 años en la oposición en 2007 ganó la
elección gracias a una imagen
conciliadora con los empresarios y su
antiguo rival eeuu
[Aplausos]
pero desde esa fecha sus críticos le
acusan de desmantelar el estado de
derecho asfixiar a la prensa y partidos
opositores incluso modificó la
constitución para nombrar a su esposa
como vicepresidente en 2018 rompió
relaciones con la empresa privada y
detonaron masivas protestas en su contra
que saldaron con más de 300 muertos y
miles de restos aislado por la comunidad
internacional ortega encarceló a sus
verdaderos contrincantes liberando el
camino para un nuevo mandato que sus
críticos llaman la consolidación de una
dictadura
[Música]